savona salve come si permette di stare
lì va dai ancora per russo maledetto si
può scendere
io gli avrei sparato volentieri non gli
ho sparato perchè tanto lo so che è un
vetro finto quello non lo diceva niente
però ti avrei sparatori che ci posso
provare la spreca un colpo neanche
lagato pensate
ci ho provato a sparargli ma non sapeva
sicuro non pettinava le bambole zia
fammi capire un attimo qua signor
nicolai rapporti incompleto ah ecco
propria cinematica adesso ci spiega
qualsiasi cosa tipo come faccio a non
avere proietti nicolai carlos a noi
vogliono negoziare questo e mezzo morto
il annulleranno all'attacco se e questo
non ti piace vai se gli consegneremo il
vaccino prima no
quanto tempo abbiamo qualche ora forse
allora vediamo di tarcento spero che per
non dirlo consenti sei un idiota solo fi
ko a quelli sono proprio con lui
vai redditi utile perché non ho
proiettili marcino e più avanti
sì ma c'e nicolai zio te lo sei
dimenticato ecc e niccolai che poi
arriveremo al bacino e lui ce lo
prenderà un secondo prima qualcosa dice
che sta per succedere qualcosa di
bruttissimo tipo che salta in aria su
tiziano hai bisogno di fermarsi perché
stai morendo vastese accordo chiudiamo
la questione nicolai nicolai non muore
mai
invece sì adesso devo dì speriamo non si
trasformi anche lui in una roba strana
brava spara almeno ti servirà tantissimo
quello che non è morto neanche con
consiglia che lo pestano però va bene
traccia
poverino questo caso è beccato gli
schiaffi ma guarda fate un favore a chi
ha veramente fatto un favore
[Applauso]
a posto potresti fare così anche come
meno male che non ti è venuta l'idea
corri corri tanto non sparare nuvole
il culo siculo protetto che cazzo ci fa
quale mesi come fatto entrare altri
colpi per le armi colpi delle armi e la
madonna di dio colpi delle armi che vi
servono per cortesia
poi l'abbiamo non abbiamo va bene
ragazzi ho finito tutto e non posso fare
niente
fuori fuori tantissimo del morire
tantissimo devi morire e devi morire di
sparare in faccia c'è questi colpi in
faccia cioè recapiti così non so cosa
fare basta quanti siete
12 morti
fa tutto sto casino è servito a qualcosa
cosa c'è di qua a l'erba tutto per
l'erba guai a francesco madonna quale
cattiveria poi devo capire cosa c'è qua
sopra perché non hanno senso sto posto
c'è dove lo sintetizza sto siero non so
fare niente solo fare non avevo due in
chimica cosa pretendi il quadro
sintetizzare il siero sicuro ecco lo
prendo cosa serve sta roba
non so cosa sto facendo provava volo
grazie campione di coltura un campione
di enti che se avrei bisogno anche di
sparare faccio come mai adesso di salta
la festa se gli esplosivi faccia la
gente che è successo
ragazzi io ho nove colpi di armi che non
mi servono quindi perfetto sapete cosa
mi fa strano è che gli occhi anche
conservati abbastanza come proietto cioè
non è che lo usate non è che ho sparato
a caso sarà quest'ora sarei veramente
col coltellino
oddio delle cose di cilindri da no
nicchia non sono capace cosa devo fare
devo far arrivare la temperatura al
massimo tutti quanti insieme
non ho capito cosa ho fatto ok
completamente a caso cercato io volevo
arrivare sul rosso conto di quanto meno
male che non faccio il chimico ragazza
molto bene bello mi piace il siero delle
brazzo quindi vaccino
cielo è un bengala rosa c'è satana che
non ai proiettili per ucciderlo quindi
sei morta per ok fatto mi ha preso dal
condotto meno male che ho preso il
coltello dal software
se non avete preso il coltello sarei
morto
meno male non ho niente per combattere
niente quindi non muoio vogliono subito
fuggire alla struttura figo sia mi
chiami ha fatto pure male capitano vai
di questo aspetto che non so se ci sono
proiettino fuggi fuggi come se adesso
arriveranno tentacoli da ogni dove
questa piscina l'ho già vista in all in
isole shawn e non è stato bello ma cosa
spari
se la cava sempre viper osb allargherà
aiutarvi quei tre proiettili che aveva
realizzati due miei con
adesso schiacciandolo schiacciando cosa
sto facendo ragazzi che ora che non
esplosa un'altra roba
bene vai vai e allora tutto a posto
e morto il nemesi 6 mikami che ancora
vivo da figure ceo vedo dei proiettili
la cosa mi piace vedo tanti frutti la
cosa mi piace tanto medicine esplosive
sia lodato il signore prove temo di sì
ti prego si ti prego si dice brava ok
non so cosa farmene
ok stesso cosa farmene
ok graziati posto e questo è un posto
dove c'è una vostra doveva che sia che
immagino sia il nemesis
a questo punto oddio mi ricorda
tantissimo sul finale di residenti vol 2
dove quello precedente dove c'era una
stanza singola dice la tipo che lanciava
le no no no no no a colpi perfetto
prendi lo prendi oggi serve al sir
quello che sono su un proiettile l'ha
visto cosa no dal ceredo megaride alla
città serve il bacino più che a me forse
non sono stato molto bravo a fatica per
e un'astens
la cosa che conta sonatori data potrà
anche non avere preso ma io sono in
questo business per fare soldi quale
facciamo mai là sotto e affronta il
nemesis io registro i dati di
combattimento e limiti fai del tuo
meglio e forse non mi servirà immagini
d'accordo
si registra i dati del combattimento che
ti volevo dire senti giovanni però io
non ho progetti
se vuoi lo faccio ma non ho proiettili
cosa cazzo vuoi che faccia contro lei
mesi io non ho letti lì cosa faccio
eccoli troppo di preti perché ti dà la
pistola santo di dio
non so proprio come poter fare questa
cosa ok
prendi come ci penso io pur bravo
se avessi letto
marcato pure non può
sono praticamente morto non è creatura
ok
si sicuro carlos
certo come dici tu
sempre
pregate buono
gli ho sparato con la pistola usata
perché non posso fare niente uccido con
la pistola
[Applauso]
minchia che schiaffo sembra così morto
se si prende la comoda tesoro tanto
tranquilla non c'è nessun problema mica
si rialza quello addio magari a minchia
potrebbe essere un'idea è alzato e
paganini in piscina queste si può
sciogliere
magari fosse morto qualcosa mi dice che
non è così
abbiamo veramente di è esploso in faccia
qualsiasi cosa non sarà neanche questo
affermarlo dopo risorge dall'acido
sicuro non lo so ma lo guarda non ho più
neanche modo di contrastarlo no ragazzi
quest'anno
questa è un'altra zona di combattimento
e io non ho colpi vi prego è finita
dammi il vaccino figlio di [ __ ]
i porti denaro
l'uomo possiamo diventare soci ora butta
l'amo
lea
a sportivo salvo scebba the hutt che
cazzo questo è il nei mesi scorsi
squartato non hai mai mai mai vista una
creatura così in chiave dire i suoi date
potrebbero valere milioni ma sai come no
la città sta per esplodere e perché la
vita non ha prezzo
buona fortuna c'è chi seguito mai appesa
al vaccino
tu che farai mai o non abbiamo più tempo
della camera ma che cosa avrei niente
anche se gli posso tirare la pistola in
testa grazie al metal gear
certo certo gil ammazzi una volta per
tutte guarda come lo ammazzi guarda qua
come gli si rilanci le bombolette in
testa forse muore forse muore e gil stai
facendo
il fucile della madonna
salve baron figlia suri metal gear due
porti una uguale ma stai scherzando
questa norma fonte
no non c'è la roma che non ai caricatori
attiva sì sì vado poggia poi appoggia
per dare appoggio per terra poi già per
terra brano certo gli ho tirato di
proiezione è però mi colpisce mi
colpisce mi colpisce non posso
ecco io faccio continua a spingere
forse ho capito cosa devo fare fermi
tutti avete anche ormai lo faccio nel
dettaglio la festa senza pietà
forse devo sparare a quelli
no non si spara quelli non si muove il
braccio imperfetto spacchiamo lì tutte
le lebbre bus sono la dottoressa fitball
popper hyun mi sono staccato però sto
bene
nel dubbio però lo colpisco che però non
è che ciò che con tutte queste munizioni
per farlo quindi teoricamente devo anche
muovermi c'è solo il pompa che non serve
a niente però mi avvicino provo
al momento preciso per ricaricare
perfetto cade per terra ok
cosa fate prima qua che mi sembra forse
principare c'è lui cade quando cadde io
posso spingersi a fare ok
1 certo due morti di che erano tutte qui
devo rifare questa rosa
ci vuole poi il cui raggio ha spaccato
anche il muro dietro pensate dovremmo
esserci regalo
io ragazzino no guarda guarda te otto
colpi per lì per il fucile e poi ho
finito non ho più mi accusa quindi o lo
uccido all uccidono niente non possono
anche farlo fuori un'altra volta perché
non mi bastano i proietti vai vidic è
morto non posso fare di niente
sì ha ringraziato gesù cristo ha quindi
a zero punti in bocca e spari buono
[Musica]
una male io mi chiamo studi
a posto
madonna si è creata la galleria santo di
dio che potenza quell'arma in b
adesso adesso adesso è morto credo mi
stupirei se no anche se non penso adesso
sono salutati di proietti ma mi chiamava
non c'è non ci siamo sempre stati non
c'erano pure prima no perché non li ho
visti poi c'è pure un arma
ma non c'erano anche prima questi
c'erano dei proiettili
meno male che avete visti suscita farlo
senza ok
c'era un proiettile ai lati che non
nuovi madonna quanti mi sei adesso
capito credo il gioco tutto sto casino è
comunque dove devo andare
passo per il barca no quale che schifo
sacrosanto gesù va bene e proietti dice
no non penso servono però io però cavo
non avevo visto che vorrei proietti dei
lati che pirla va bene
nicolai beh mi servivano per lui almeno
quello anche tre granate particolari
no però dubito che sanno che carlo sono
ripreso
quei carlos questo nell ascensore che ci
sono anche due
sarà questa una figata chiudere entrambe
le volte
bello minchia la luce del sole
c'è la luce solo un cazzo e buio però
almeno o gesù è morto carlo ma tutte ste
robe le vediamo anche dal lato di carlos
perché non sei sono esistono non
riuscirai a per quale allora questo che
vuole
non è vero
no ti rendi conto di cosa gli ha appena
fatto
non so e non mi importa gli ordini del
mio cliente sono di distruggere la
umbrella alloggiato il missile pureness
così insieme
addio jack valentine avresti dovuto
ascoltarmi al momento giusto ma stavo
carlos madonna tutto questo film che
cacchio stai facendo sparagli chi la sta
facendo gili ecco no sennò ammazzerò
anche colpi rai
ok vallo fallo guarda i suoi capelli li
fai solo un favore allo mancato banchisa
sei forte l'ho mancato tantissimo era
davvero lei e l'ha detto che non puoi
stare senza di me e spara in una cella
casa fuoco l'ho mancato rega you say
guardate se stoppate il video in quel
momento l'ho mancato dalla sicuro ei
faceva una scampagnata sì
ogni cosa ha il suo prezzo persino
ridurre il mondo incendi
emi per chilo
te lo dirò se mettere rai politico
pagherò qualsiasi cella a lei di soldi
ne frega un cazzo sei una storia
sei una stupida se morirò non saprai mai
la metà
preferisco scoprirla da sola
[Musica]
no
e stato molto divertente
[Musica]
cazzo rivi
ma si vede almeno quando arrivano i
missili speriamo di sì o no
spero che non lo sappiamo che gli amici
sei morto ok non sono ancora sicuro e
dal taglio
ci si
intanto c'è passato di fianco
vado
un bar caccia lac
ma teoricamente anche la vita
per niente bene
vada a posto
adesso è finita
noi spunta di nuovo il nemesis dal
niente
addio tentacolo nemesis sarebbe non mi
stupirei tra l'altro tanto come se
l'esplosione
[Musica]
dei proiettili
la causa
è carlos quei capelli sarà quello
[Musica]
da vedere
promisi a me stessa che l'umbrella
avrebbe condiviso le sue ceneri con
raccon city che l'avrei distrutta per
sempre
gli scorso e che davano iniziato la
serie ho visto i primi pareri delle
recensioni che erano abbastanza negative
nelle sessioni sono negative secondo me
perché il capitolo prima di residenti vi
era un molto bello c'era era incredibile
e quindi è la propria difficile tener
testa al predecessore proprio
difficilissimo io credo che questo
residenti volo sia ovviamente inferiore
a quello di prima ma non è neanche un
brutto gioco c'è io ho sentito dire no
perché sa non è bello però non è bello
come quello prima ma quando tu fai un
lavoro talmente fatto bene è proprio
difficile tenerli testa quindi non
capisco e ci sta quindi ragazzi problemi
sia piaciuto spero che la serie vi sia
piaciuta fatemi sapere se volete ad
episodio no perché ha tanto fini buoni
incubi con il nemesis a tutti e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
della ragazza
[Musica]